[Music]
how's it goin breasts my name's Perry
and welcome to Thomas was alone it's a
wonderful game about rectangles and
squares actually with personalities it's
actually one of my favorite indie games
I I I'm not kind of Babylon why I love
it so much I just kind of want to show
it to you bros and i think you bros will
really love it it's very narrative
driven so i can't really talk too much
so I'll try to keep my mouth shut and
just give you Bruce a good feeling on
the game
hopefully you'll you'll see why I love
it so much and we're gonna start in the
middle of it so I'm gonna try to explain
what's going on everyone so this red
one's name is Thomas I feel good because
I don't have to name him it's always
like what should I call him this one is
a jump they're potato fry or whatever
and then we finally have Chris the fact
tiny one chris is a bit sassy I don't
really like Chris that much but I'm I
get to fill in crystal first of all
begin the words and or something like
that right John was happy to keep
helping he felt it was important to his
image that he was seen to help the
little guys okay well I'm glad you're
maintaining your image as a potato fry
John so yeah all of these have like
different abilities Thomas can jump mid
to high John can jump super high and
Chris well Chris can't do really
I'm skinny but you work together
with all these rectangles and chips and
to solve puzzles I guess and progressing
it's a very simple concept but it works
it worked well this game was made by my
crystal which I recently actually met
him in Brighton it's probably watching
this I like I could just see him judging
everything I do I feel like you brother
chao chih-hao but i am solving this
puzzle there we go finally okay so I'll
try to add it further on where you get
more than filling up the narrative
probably what I notice right away when I
play this is how amazing the soundtrack
is and does a lot for me I'm I'm a
sucker for a good good soundtrack not
gonna lie
[Music]
and I am a sucker for parcels - yeah
back in the day when I started my
channel there was just I don't know we
find if I remember that I didn't you
said in my videos back in the day and
it's kind of hard to think and solve
puzzle is at the same God point proven
at the same time so people would just
get genuinely upset our slowest at
solving puzzles and it it become like a
thing we didn't mind them so much either
the red one Thomas and her charming way
of applauding every time double jumps
it's so cute I don't know oh god what
the John doesn't wanna hang out
laughs as I mentioned before they Mike
this is a good job at telling their
personalities in a subtle way that that
still gives you a good idea of what
they're like I don't know I don't know
what I'm talking about
go Chris God John hell yeah
teamwork I don't know if higher
rectangles can come by angry orange one
was less immediately likable but yeah is
unlimited cynicism and tilting who's
John okay
[Music]
there we go you did it Chris Friday you
may go Thomas you're not alone anymore
all the fancy go through this portal to
finish the level this was interesting to
Nugget this would require coordination
balance and timing everything Chris
doesn't have John was sure that dots
would be lost he was happy to guide them
to triumph of course John you're not God
I wonder if I can do this oh my god
genius kid strikes again
[Music]
any coordination if you're a
genius look at me there we go I have
played this game before so I am actually
create am terrible I don't remember
being this bad that's what the Ducks
were for they were there to extend
John's reach to make his performance
even more impressive John liked the
thought he decided oh you're so nice
John thank you so much oh oh yes this is
my my favorite character of the game
she's just a nice full butterfly
so this was how Claire would die she
knew could happen eventually
she was rubbish at jumping
oh yeah Yardley she felt a little like
her continued existence was breaking
some kind of natural order I don't know
how I feel like throwing clay and
crumbling pillow was a dramatic death
she supposed this is Dan Bros was not
she doesn't worry it was at that moment
that Claire realized she had superpowers
hold your horses Claire you're not that
great but okay fine
[Music]
say I know this is sorry there's no
getting around that you couldn't be a
superhero without a cape but I didn't
want confusion it's true but Thomas is
get out okay I'm serving so just clear
you knew what you were dealing with
Claire was all about communication you
know floating in water which was her
superpower it's a pretty awesome
superpower to have there's an old fat
people float good in water well just
make uh-huh anyway I know this isn't the
typical PewDiePie game but it's a game
that I really love and I'm happy to
finally be showing to you bros and
french fries go in there
[Music]
right they're not my skinny friends for
I am Claire and I will save you if then
she wonderful needed to come up with a
superhero name as soon as possible
rubbish and it's a pretty bad superhero
name how about you Rose tell me a good
name I don't know Clara the bear Claire
the underwear solitaire Claire my secret
love affair there we go
it's not really a super hair day but hey
get enough all right all aboard the
Claire Express the Claire I don't even
know declare Claire declares it's
raining Claire arrived just in time
which was of course the perfect moment
the superheroes to arrive of course but
IRA knows what she's doing obviously I
got there Thomas
[Music]
isn't this game wonderful
III really hope you bros I was try to
pick up this game and enjoyed yourself
to rise Clare vowed to save this little
rectangle in as many restarts as it took
[Music]
KY is just the best let's be honest
Claire wondered if Thomas would make a
good psychic she more the lone Avenger
time she liked that soul hero in a world
of rectangles and conveniently placed
pools of toxic water could be near the
place I think Thomas should be the
secret love affair but hey maybe this is
me I'm actually gonna end it here I'm
sorry if it's a bit abrupt but I don't
want to spoil too much for the story I
want you boys to enjoy this yourself
this is last chance to pick it up at the
bundle right now I'm sorry if I shove
this thing down your throat for the past
week but it's for a good cause
so I'm okay with it I I said still hope
it was enjoyable to watch if it was
leave a like let me know hit subscribe
you come abroad today and I'll see in
the next one
stay awesome friends love you
[Music]
got a dog would laugh at any joke huh